good afternoon everyone my name is Steve
wasnít and I teach at the Yale Law
School it's my pleasure and privilege to
introduce justice Cuellar for the second
of the castle lectures this year I have
to say it's been 23 years since justice
Cuellar graduated the Yale Law School
and he looks exactly the same as he did
when he was a bright earnest and hard
work when he was a bright and earnest
and hard-working student yesterday in
her introduction of justice Cuellar
professor Rosen bluth spoke of justice
Quay ours immigrant roots his
educational achievements his government
service his teaching and scholarship as
a professor of law at Stanford and his
appointment as the first Mexican
immigrant to serve as a justice on the
Supreme Court of California now I think
in the current political moment in which
we're all suffering through it's fair to
wonder whether had justice Cuellar been
born 20 years later whether he would be
sitting on the Supreme Court of
California with the current
administration in any event it's my
pleasure and privilege to introduce him
yesterday he spoke of the politics and
policy involved in addressing problems
that in his words bedevil the modern
world among other things he spoke of
climate change nuclear weapons
weaponization poverty mass incarceration
especially of african-american males and
he included he concluded by asking where
do we go from here and he then had a
very interesting discussion of the
importance of social movements and
political coalition building in
addressing those problems the lecture
provoked a lively back-and-forth between
justice Cuellar and primarily
undergraduate economics ethics politics
and economics majors about much of what
he had talked about I thought it was a
very lively exchange between them
the really showed me what a wonderful
law professor he must have been because
he really encouraged disagreement and
then engaged with it I think we can
anticipate that today's lecture and the
follow-up question and answer period
will be equally entertaining and
provocative and so at the conclusion
there will be a question and answer
period that will last with help as long
as yesterday's I want to emphasize that
students are going to be called on first
I know that some of you who are former
students would love to participate
my friend Michael for sure but we're
gonna hold off on calling on them until
after students have all had a chance to
engage and be taught something by
justice Cuellar so it is my pleasure to
introduce him Thank You Steven thank you
all of you for being here it's just a
tremendous honor to be here I'm I said
that yesterday I'm gonna say it again
because it still feels like an amazing
just humbling honor to be here I should
add that I have vivid memories of when I
was taking trial practice and professor
Wisner was kind of a rock star in that
field so he would just amble about and
go from trial practice class to trial
practice just joining the instructors
and giving that last like tidbit of
special wisdom and one night he came to
the class it was in the evening
somewhere in the basement of Yale Law
School and I had been working really
really hard I'm trying to come up with a
persuasive argument for why a particular
piece of evidence in a simulation we
were doing should not be admitted and I
refined and refined my arguments and I
felt confident and the instructor had
been emphasizing the importance of
speaking with confidence so professor
Wisner came in and the instructor said
well Steve why don't you serve as a
judge and hear the arguments back and
forth and I said this is my chance so I
launched into this carefully worded like
confident but not like overbearing
argument about like why this was here
saying it shouldn't come in and if it
was you know and why no exception to the
hearsay rule
and ultimately I said and if even if you
don't agree with me about that it's like
so prejudiced the print additional and
so on and then I stopped and there was a
total silence in the room and it looked
over and present had been kind of going
like this and it says like no I'd allow
it I hope I can do better this time all
right so two years ago I was invited to
a class at Stanford on AI safety to
explain why a lawyer like me had been
growing increasingly interested in
artificial intelligence and what I
thought might be useful for students
interested in this topic to know about
how society generally approaches the
problem of regulation how safe is this
product can I drink this water without
getting sick what's in the air and so on
there I found some students who were
pretty engaged and creative there were
about 50 no maybe 45 students most of
them almost all of them computer science
many undergrads but mostly grad students
a couple of students who were technical
but not computer science so aero-astro
mechanical engineering and so on I
talked about the things you would
imagine that somebody with my background
would talk about I talked about how
society deals with a collective action
problems involving there our approach to
new technologies like aviation or
nuclear I talked about agency capture I
talked about the role of civil society
and spurring government into action I
talked about litigation and how it works
and it's part of the discussion I
suggested at one point that in my
considered humble experience in
government it was very clear that deep
technical knowledge was pretty important
to almost anything government did to get
it right so I gave the example of how
around Environmental Protection whether
your concern was more endangered species
or climate it really helped to
understand the science and some of that
knowledge ought to live not in
contractors but inside government so I
suggested that students consider working
in civil service nonprofit organizations
civil society government running for
office and then I made it kind of enough
comment like you don't have to take it
your whole career that's like yours an
analogy like in law sometimes people go
private sector
but they spend a couple years doing that
you might even try it for this summer
student raises his hand and says
professor I hate to say this I'm really
sorry I don't know how this is going to
sound but do you have actually any idea
how much money we can make working in
the private sector even just for summer
there was a silence much like in this
room my mind was kind of racing I was
fascinated sociologically I was dismayed
I had that sort of moment where you can
see yourself talking just seconds in the
future and almost anything that I could
imagine saying sounded awfully preachy
it sounded like how my daughter looks
when I start saying something to her
that she doesn't like to hear which
fortunately doesn't happen that often
and she starts going like this right so
I thought about Max Weber distinction
between an ethic of consequence and an
ethic of responsibility I thought about
all the difficult technical work to
weigh the costs and benefits of policies
to govern autonomous vehicles and drones
and how I hope that some of the people
in that room would be part of that
discussion but I'm not going to tell you
what happens I'm gonna leave you in
suspense until tomorrow
at which point I will tell you what
happened because you know I have to give
you some reason to show up tomorrow
right it's very rare I get the chance to
to give lectures like this and I have
more than one day to do it but but when
I think about that exchange today I
can't help but think of a lot of people
technical people and lawyers who are
technical people to making decisions
about their careers in candor I also
think about people who are weighing how
they can use their appetite for risk and
their time and their effort to make
change happen I think about people in
Hong Kong for example making judgments
may be some spur of the moment just on
the fly but maybe also quite intricate
once maybe they even take out a pen like
this one and start working out the
expected utility I don't know but it
it's it's a striking thing to imagine
when you think about those choices
lately as you probably know the
authorities have been using water
cannons to spray blue dye and the dye
not only stings of course but it along
with facial recognition it diminishes
the possibility that the protesters can
do so
anonymously and surely adds urgency to a
version of Professor professor Peter
singer's question about what is the most
good that you can do speaking of which
in a former castle lecture professor
Peter Singer laudably called on us all
not only to do good but to be thoughtful
and rigorous about how we might do the
most good and in a way the conversation
I was trying to have with the students
in that AI safety class was about that
doing the most good might be
accomplished by giving a part of
yourself as he very eloquently says in
this book through organ donation sharing
some of the copious wealth that a
graduate from an institution like this
one can amass dedicating a portion of
your career to serving the public
although professor singers account is
grounded in and primarily aimed at
debates about how a person can do the
most good
you can argue and I would that there's a
substantial convergence between the
ambition of effective altruism and the
project of rigorously wearing the costs
and the benefits of policies that we
take on behalf of the public as is no
doubt the hope of many who believe in
effective altruism this project of
weighing the custom benefits of social
action has made an important difference
over the last half century or so in the
hands of some practitioners and in
response to certain scholarly ideas in
many quarters the project of weighing
consequences of being a good
consequentialist has grown ever more
rigorous in its aspirations with the
goal of being as much quantitative as
possible in tallying up costs and
benefits with a particular within a
particular domain such as a rule
governing drones or a policy to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions in some
respects this project has furnished the
tools to help us weigh how environmental
harms endangered human activity how they
were also engendered to some extent by
human activity over time policymakers
and courts have tried to sharpen the
value the the evaluative saw by
requiring analysts to consider not only
the merits of a particular action
but also the comparative merits of one
action relative to another and this to
fits with what I gather effective
altruists aspire to treat as a desirable
norm for those trying to weigh the
merits not only if you know doing good
or not doing good but how do you do the
most good my question
mostly motivating the rest of the talk
is this one what should we make of the
many seemingly attractive policies that
turn out to be the most good you can't
do buy the most good you can't do I mean
for example that the ideal policy or
altruistic action is something that we
can envision or even plan but either
it's not realistic to execute
successfully giving an existing
conditions or it's indeed possible to
implement but has undesirable downstream
consequences that cut against pursuing
that course of action a rule
aggressively expanding the category of
employee relative to contractor not
unheard of in California
maybe for some evaluators so attractive
is to be nearly optimal but it may
require an available resources or in
force or engender a better or a backlash
limiting the agency's legal authority or
a person may find that her most valuable
altruistic uses to work with poor
children at a local inner-city school
but the school in question is run poorly
and unlikely to fully support or value
the teacher's labor on a closely related
note sometimes a policy or
interpretation that's desirable from one
perspective such as allowing people to
recover economic losses in a negligent
section arising from a natural calamity
such as a gas leak turns out to be all
but impossible to administer finally
sometimes the sensible measure
addressing a discrete problem like the
health of people who consume a certain
kind of food may exacerbate through
political backlash for instance the risk
of failure to enact a policy or
legislation valuable in mitigating the
risks of climate change or reducing
risks posed by an aging nuclear arsenal
right
these most good you can't do type
questions they're obviously worth asking
in any sensible real-world conversation
about policy or about altruism and
perhaps in some conversations about
legal interpretations were appropriate
but for reasons I'll explain they raise
more cross-cutting and profound
issues with the arsenal of analytic
strategies and assumptions we routinely
use to render the world tractable and
safe for consequential evaluation so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start with a few examples that I think
will hope ground some of what I'm
talking about
I'll offer some instances where the
traditional approach now traditional
approach to weighing costs and benefits
trying to use as much quantification as
possible seem to have served society
less than perfectly then I'll talk about
a few ideas to improve our capacity to
assess consequences that also maybe bear
some relationship to the conversation we
had yesterday about big risks and then I
will end which is good because normally
I don't talk this long so let's begin as
so many days to do with eggs in 2009 I
was handling among other things the food
safety portfolio for the Obama
administration working in the White
House Domestic Policy Council working
closely with people in the Agriculture
Department and the Food and Drug
Administration and Centers for Disease
Control so I worked on the latter stages
of a rule that it was about to be
promulgated by the FDA on egg safety to
prevent salmonella
I found the cost-benefit process
valuable as it brought more precision to
our evaluation of measures to prevent
contamination at farms particularly
since some farms were going to get bad
news they were not going to qualify for
an exemption that applied to farms that
had a small number of hens relatively
small and they were gonna have to expend
time energy money doing things that
seemed like intrusive from a Washington
DC perspective so in response for
example to concerns that the industry
might call into question the future of
what was left of the egg industry and
discrete parts of the country Hawaii
being the most prominent example it was
helpful to point to an analysis that the
rule was expected to prevent about
seventy nine thousand foodborne
illnesses a year and to prevent 30
statistical deaths caused by consumption
of contaminated eggs near the edge of my
awareness but still clear in my mind if
I focused were the many assumptions that
this analysis was been
not only about compliance with rodent
spotting requirements that were built
into the rule but also about more
profound matters the focus on aggregate
welfare but of discrete individuals
simplified by use of what we in the law
world called the Kaldor Hicks criterion
to leave aside where the welfare gains
and costs are going to fall and the
focus on aggregate increases in welfare
the aspiration that quantify were ever
ever possible the relatively static
analytical framework so we weren't
measuring how does the world change over
five years eight years ten years of
complying with this rule over time you
know if for example norms come from
partly the learning that people do in
these farms about how to comply does
that change compliance costs over you
know five years eight years or whatever
it was clear to me that we tended to
rely on this approach which could be
called conventional or neo-orthodoxy
cost-benefit analysis for a variety of
understandable normative and descriptive
reasons ok the calculations are more
tractable when the world is depicted in
simpler terms sometimes the statutes
themselves that we were implementing
limit the breadth of the analysis the
reach of what some might call a kind of
neoliberal paradigm and political
economy made some of the assumptions not
only useful but seemed natural and
sensible like thinking about individuals
and individual welfare is quite atomized
past dependence within organizations
reinforces cultural assumptions and
personal agendas that encourage the
employees of existing procedures I could
imagine the conversations with OMB with
FDA if I said have you thought for a
moment about modeling to some extent the
diminished welfare of a whole family
when somebody gets sick are you kidding
why would I do that you know why isn't
this the right way to go about it what
was less clear to me then or now is the
extent to which the conversation about
any rule should be expected to screen
out a variety of Prudential questions
and critiques of such analyses that are
honestly less candidly and acknowledged
in this process could we use new methods
to build in subtle features into the
analysis
like dynamic changes in industry norms
assuming the statute leaves some
discretion on this front what's the
right timing for the rule given the
administration's broader agenda how
might the rule interact with other
health related policies such as
negotiation over the Affordable Care Act
if there's a way for the rule to achieve
the vast majority of the benefits in a
matter that's far easier to administer
but not all the benefits is that worth
making that trade on a more familiar
note should we relax assumptions that
costs and benefits are to be quantified
as much as possible and instead
routinely seek to preserve a qualitative
dimension it's hard to imagine that the
most sensible answer to advancing social
welfare across the board is always going
to be a resounding no even if one has
near boundless confidence in the
analysis trying to optimize on issue
specific considerations across every
area of the world of scarcity - trait of
capacity and institutional capacity is
risky particularly if there's a
legitimate reason to assign special
importance to certain cross-cutting
goals like mitigating the risk of
climate change or managing our
relationship with artificial
intelligence
just as a principled effective altruists
might want to ask whether the strategy
she's chosen to do the most good is
lawful treat that as at least one
consideration so might a principled
public official considering what to do
about the range of all these
considerations might also want to know
can I do it in my job does this fit with
separation of powers does the statute
let me do it what I'd suggest is a
limited claim without meaning to dismiss
such questions is simply this we should
say take seriously the case for more
capacious and candid consideration of
consequences in the many situations
where the legal materials are less than
clear or where they clearly permit some
discretion or where policymakers are
designing institutional rules in the
first place
not infrequently considerations
involving administrability institutional
capital broader cross-cutting priorities
already play some role in decision
making and are worth acknowledging with
more candor and ignoring such Prudential
factors or applying the more
conventional flavor of cosmetic methods
can conceivably lead to outcomes that
serves
ladies interest less well in the long
run by making it harder for policymakers
to consider what unquestionably matters
to the entire enterprise of governing
okay let me go to my next part all of
these arguments might be less compelling
to me I might have more confidence that
we should just stick to a simple
straightforward method we kind of know
elaborate on it somewhat incrementally
the way some of its advocates might
suggest if the application of this
conventional issue specific cost-benefit
analysis had been an unalloyed success
at least in the US and at least with
regard to regulation that picture is
more complicated that's the punchline
and it's probably not surprising to you
right
so sometimes we under way benefits and
over where costs in other cases
analytical methods such as minimization
of exposure based on an endangerment
finding like with leading gasoline turns
out to become quite popular and later
gets cost-benefit justified but at the
time we did it it would have been hard
to do that and in still other cases all
this cost benefits stuff is a little
orthogonal to the fights about legal
interpretation and about Policy
Priorities that end up having the
pivotal effect in doing something like
when the EPA finally got around to
proceeding on climate change-related
regulations so let me give just a few
examples and this is like the riskiest
part of my talk because whenever I start
talking about things like the EPA's
regulation of azm pesticides and stuff
like that like the audience will begin
to sort of tune out so bear with me I
the hardest work in putting together
stock was shrinking and shrinking with
sections so this is about you know as
quick as I can make it
1978 the EPA issued a ruling to
phase-out a CFCs chlorofluorocarbons the
agency revised its cost estimates of the
phase-out as compliant compliance costs
fell yet the actual phase-out ultimately
cost about 30% less than the estimates
the agency looks on why was the
discrepancy there well mostly because
the agency failed to account for how
soon the market would adjust it's a
variation of the point I was making with
the egg safety point right institutions
learned that's in some ways the whole
premise behind aspects of neoclassical
economics they respond to incentives
right that's like not not true
when it comes to regulatory compliance
but there's very rarely a dynamic
element built into these models and so
that CFC regulation was mispriced a very
substantial degree in terms of under
estimating regulatory benefits the EPA's
regulation of the ACM pesticide I think
shows just one example of stakes when it
the EPA conducted the cost-benefit
analysis it failed to consider the full
range of pesticide alternatives failed
to adequately define the level of human
harm necessary to trigger pesticide
cancellation failed to account for the
underreporting and late emergence of
pesticide related illnesses so in the
end a perfectly understandable effort to
make the world more easy to model gave
us a very inaccurate sense of what this
was actually gonna do in the world
sometimes less than adequate analyses
were associated with policies that made
some important contributions in the long
run so here it's 1973 the EPA decides
it's going to move forward with an
endangerment finding of lead in gasoline
but the logic behind that is very
different from the way we aspire to do
CBA now it wasn't like at every dosage
what's the impact and when did the sort
of lines of cost and benefit cross
instead it was sort of like letters not
great let's try to limit the exposure to
this as much as we can in effect so now
we know a lot more about the health
effects that come from less such as
reduced learning capacity or illogical
disorders high blood pressure and these
would have been quite difficult to
disentangle from other causes back then
given that if you're maximally rigorous
disentangling crustacean is kind of like
the hardest thing in social sciences so
like what room do you give regulators to
say we know enough to go forward and
let's learn more as we go along I would
say you can tell a similar story about
OSHA's 1974 rule limiting workplace
exposure for vinyl chloride I don't mean
to rag on the 1970s I was born in the
1970s but a lot of these things did not
work perfectly then they still don't
work perfectly and then I just want to
say a little bit about the remarkable
story of how the EPA came to decide that
our be forced to decide that it ought to
take climate change in limiting
greenhouse gas emissions seriously and
here my main point is simply note that
anyone who thinks that sort of evidence
data and the right cost-benefit analysis
is sort of the right way to go out to
grapple with the fact that sometimes
crucial moves in policymaking and in law
happen for a different reason they
happen based on legal interpretations
and who wins elections and you know
there's more nuance there you could say
well why don't we make that more sort of
like responsive to the right kind of
cost-benefit analysis but for what it's
worth
the EPA realized some years after the
Clean Air Act was enacted so in 1998
that there was a very plausible
interpretation of the Clean Air Act that
justified greenhouse gas emissions
regulation and by the time the EPA got
around to issuing proposed rules and
getting comments responding to petitions
a new administration to come in deciding
that actually that legal interpretation
was sort of wrong didn't believe it and
the EPA pulled back the litigation that
ensued ended up before the US Supreme
Court and finally the US Supreme Court
decided that no it wasn't sort of like a
weighing of costs and benefits as such
it was simply that the way the statute
was written if the EPA had jurisdiction
over this and it had a petition that it
hadn't adequately responded to saying
you should then deal with human impacts
of this the EPA had a responsibility to
do it to this day I think that's perhaps
the most consequential environmental law
decision from the US Supreme Court so
all this to me suggests that we can do
better right I'm not saying that I would
like to do without any CDA
but it's like a not solved problem and
just how technical precise and rigorous
we can make it without losing some of
the nuances it's a hard question and
here I just want to pivot back for a
moment to the effective altruism stuff
because in a way I'm plainly sympathetic
for the idea that we can all be more
reflective about how we think about the
opportunity cost of the altruism we do
but there is a weak claim in a stronger
version of a claim worth disentangling
and the weak claim is that society can
be more systematic and assessing what's
good that is worth doing per
disentangling the pathos of persuasion
or emotion that generally galvanizes
action from the logos of why exactly we
believe one path is better than another
this insight scales you could say from
individuals to organizations like
private philanthropic foundations or
even governments which is one reason why
some attention to effective altruism I
think belongs in a discussion of how
government waste costs and benefits even
this weak claim I think is important in
emphasizing some of the different ways
that people can make reasonable positive
differences in the world not just going
by the instinct of showing up in a
refugee camp and becoming an aid worker
but maybe by earning plenty of money and
donating a lot of that money but that's
the weaker claim the struggle claim
captures a deeper ambition that I think
is more similar to what motivates the
most enthusiastic proponents of hardcore
quantified cost-benefit analysis and
government and that's what we can design
a relatively the reliable metric for
ranking possible altruistic actions and
that we can expect it to serve as a
sufficiently compelling guide to
individual and institutional priorities
that it should Trump no pun intended
other considerations such as how much
you love to do something or whether you
think it will inspire other people to
this stronger claim I think the right
answer is deep skepticism for one human
social life as we've seen is incredibly
complicated tipping points and
interdependent utility means a far from
obvious far from obviously good
seemingly wasteful active altruism can
greatly impact meaningful changes in the
probability of achieving societal goals
somebody protesting around the world in
Hong Kong can inspire somebody in
California to try to push for a better
language access for litigants in
California courts for another the many
attractive philanthropic or altruistic
options were less viable in a
second-best world the point I started
with the ideal of applying rigor isn't
the same thing as the hubris of
expecting a single viable metric to
serve as the deciding factor in a
conversation about the myriad ways that
some individual can pursue noble ends
and the many ways those pursuits can
fall short of their goals so let me turn
to
envisioning what I might call a more
thoughtful conversation about these
topics so I would paint a more
complicated picture where there's room
to draw certain lines with greater
precision in the analysis of costs and
benefits but there's also room to
interpret blurrier divides and intricate
splotches of color that inevitably
sometimes evoke something like a
Rorschach test better to embrace the
challenges with humility and to do that
I think we should start by moving beyond
the evaluate but we should start by
thinking about what it might mean to
move beyond the evaluation of isolated
policy or altruistic silos consider
again the typical application of
cost-benefit analysis we take isolated
policy problems and presume to work out
the most sensible policy response
holding the rest of the world constant I
imagine this is what some practitioners
of effective altruism would hope to do
as well yet nearly any sensible
inference about the consequences of a
policy depend on a series of assumptions
about the rest of law society politics
and economics that frustration with a
new rule won't undermine the viability
of another valuable rule or policy for
instance or that it won't create
regulatory disparities in safety or cost
in the event that other regulatory
domains face a more treacherous
political economy years and years ago
mark Hellman made a somewhat analogous
point with respect to the evaluation of
the costs and benefits of legal rules in
the common law he emphasised wealth
effects to explain why marginal analysis
of property entitlement rules was
questionable and this is what he said it
is simply unclear why we treat any
rulers marginal rather than recognizing
that we must simultaneously assign all
entitlements if the regime as a whole is
to be efficient if it's not the case
that there are only trivial wealth
effects from the assignment of all
entitlements it's unclear why we can
ignore the general wealth effects of
entitlements by assuming that we have
correctly said all other entitlements
except the one we're discussing I think
basically that's the same point that I'm
making with some nuanced distinctions
indeed so in the egg safety context if
you don't think about those other
effects it's not at all obvious that you
can claim that this is cost-benefit
justified now obviously shaping domain
across
and lots of policy areas is really hard
and is no easier than expecting all
effective altruists to coordinate their
behavior simultaneously in order to
maximize their impact what may be more
feasible and to me has a compelling
logic behind it is to work on enhancing
capacity to consider the interdependence
of various actions whether by
governments or by altruists and where
possible their relationship to the most
urgent issues facing society bolstering
trust in public institutions is often an
example of what I'd consider a
defensible consideration
although judicial arse work also
poignant Lee makes the case for distrust
as an element of liberalism of fear the
existence of that very distress can
serve as a productive constraint that
public officials would be foolish to
ignore important civic goals might
depend on the extent to which citizens
are more likely to comply with costly
demands from their governments for
example to change energy consumption
patterns or to engage in military
service because of this it's not
implausible for policymakers as well as
altruist to consider the factors that
scholars like Margaret Levy identified
in studying the relationship between
citizens their government we'd want to
ask how policy decisions contribute to
the perception that government is
trustworthy and that other citizens
comply and engage in what she called
ethical reciprocity so let me now talk
about a related but different point this
is about embracing changes in the
paradigm structuring the whole
analytical conversation about how we
weigh costs and benefits new paradigms
lead to refined thinking in generally
embracing simplifying assumptions to
deal with such complexity many
practitioners and scholars are in a
position to affect how society weighs
costs and benefits and they've been
influenced by a paradigmatic set of
ideas about the economy that some might
call neoliberalism and I'm going to just
use scare quotes because I I know we
could probably spend hours discussing
exactly what falls into her out of that
so whether it's precisely the right
terminology or not surely the scope of
what we consider technically feasible
and acceptable cost-benefit analysis
will change as we develop refined ideas
about the relationship between the macro
and the micro economy about the
interplay between
so forces in economic behavior and about
the range of legitimate reactions people
may have to changing circumstances
history always delivers almost always
intriguing insights even though at the
cost of actually living through them
sometimes in the rise of modern
cost-benefit analysis in the US and its
relationship to some of the ideas that
are part of a paradigm like this
presidents Reagan and Clinton turn out
to be pretty pivotal figures right
Reagan forged a powerful and interesting
coalition between factions whose primary
interests were economic and some
supporters whose primary interests were
very different they were more of a
religious social and cultural nature
Clinton addressed the decline of a
traditional coalition and his party by
bringing in a set of ideas that were
familiar from what we might call the
neoliberal list fold and by embracing
some of the technical approaches to
cost-benefit analysis that had been
instantiated by the Reagan
administration against this historical
backdrop the future of applied
consequentialism will almost certainly
depend on coalition building stitching
together new ideas about how to measure
value and how to model interdependent
behavior dynamically with various
interests who can see some advantage in
embracing more nuanced methods whether
they're most concerned about flows of
capital the dignity of citizens
protection of the planet or national
security such coalition's might become
more feasible to forge as new
possibilities for weighing costs and
benefits and drawing up scenarios are
emerging as new tools open up for
possibilities to understand the economy
simulations using artificial
intelligence using agent-based modeling
can be used to discover new ways of
seeing how policies interact with each
other this creates the potential to
ground a new set of ideas about how to
model the economy not just in a more
robust view of political economy but in
different practices of model buildings
more robust connections between science
and deliberation which brings me to a
third point which I call embracing
evaluative pluralism our tool for this
era
has been in regulation this weighing of
custom benefits that proceeds in a very
particular and predictable way but in
any sensible version of a reformed
approach to this
we'd probably analyze discrete problems
by considering broader priorities and
thinking about the value of having
several different estimates or analyses
that contend for attention in fact that
might embrace a rebuttable presumption
that important policy actions should be
informed by multiple analyses maybe
three or four of them that would
highlight the distinct assumptions that
are being made and reduce the risk that
even careful decision makers will rush
to embrace a single approach as somehow
handed down from mountain on stone
tablets that are beyond question sure
sometimes even exponents of applied
consequentialism recognizing the need
for nuance but I want to just talk a
little bit about professor chaos and
steam and his voluminous and very
impressive body of work to highlight the
importance of nuances here and the
possibility of taking seriously the
weighing of costs and benefits but not
denying the moral and political
judgments they were implicit there so in
it's kind of worth contrasting I would
argue Sunstein's work in a piece called
the arithmetic of arsenic from 2002 with
some of the more confident statements
made to defend conventional cost-benefit
analysis more recently in 2018 for
example professor Sunstein said the
simplest point and the most important
was emphasized by some of Reagan's own
advisors policy should make people's
lives better officials should not rely
on intuitions interest groups polls or
documents in a nutshell quantitative
cost-benefit analysis the best available
method for assessing the effects of
regulation on social welfare contrast
that with what
Sunstein said in the arithmetic of
arsenic in 2002 so he takes the EPA in a
test for how it analyzes an arsenic
related rule to limit exposure to
arsenic under the Safe Drinking Water
Act and says you know the way they
calculated their particular cost-benefit
curve and dose response curve is highly
contingent they could have done it in a
lot of different ways and still be
scientifically accurate
and if you've done it that way you would
have found that smaller concentrations
of arsenic were justified or rather
lower thresholds and then beyond
pointing out these limitations he
emphasizes the ultimate decision still
had to rest on political value judgments
about the full extent of interest
considered and about acceptable levers
levels of risk to me this narrative
sounds are somewhat more humble notes
emphasizing the value of different
scenarios and teasing out the
implications of distinct assumptions
there's always the argument that the
crux of a decision-making process should
be kept purely technical free of
original sin as it were and then Messier
considerations about politics or social
acceptance or administrability can be
brought in at the end if they must come
because I think there is a risk of poor
decision-making or intellectual
sophistry from keeping important
decisions as anodyne as possible
I want a foreground some of the
possibilities for greater candor and
bigger picture of thinking and weighing
consequences without suggesting that we
do away entirely with CBA 2-channel
Judith Sklar I'll repeat what she says
at the end of her terrific book ordinary
vices at most she says I'm trying to
make our conversations more complete and
coherent and to review critically the
judgments we ordinarily make and the
possibilities were usually see I would
add that in the end some civic conflict
about all these domains I've talked
about how you do the most good
how much arsenic is safe to put in the
water is par for the course and rightly
so overly suppressing it is hardly a
recipe for healthy or legitimate
institutions being honest about such
conflict is just one step but an
important one in doing better on how we
decide to decide so let me end by saying
that my principle message tonight is
that we can do better in making
decisions that matter our problems with
climate and nuclear threats showcase how
much depends on factors such as economic
and political interests norms the
capacity of institutions to overcome
resistance and the dynamic changes that
we experience in all these areas so I
think we're left with at least two
recurring problems pointing in somewhat
opposite directions even if we agreed on
what goods are worth prioritizing
identifying the most good you can do
without
into account the messiness of the real
world means neglecting whether the good
can actually be realized yet as the
protesters in Hong Kong no doubt realize
sometimes the call to help build a
different world can outweigh the
legitimate claim that any anodyne
expectation of measuring expected
utility is going to really have in our
behavior the most good you can't do in
that sense is good that you might want
to do anyway because it matters to you
but an overly crabbed conception of this
not only plays down the multiple answers
to the most good you can't do question
but it also diminishes our ability to
appreciate why there's a reasonableness
in the risky action that's playing out
in some quarters including people
protesting and authoritarian governments
maybe it's right for someone to say I'm
not protesting because I'm going to do
more good by keeping my high paying job
and donating much of the salary to
deworming in Africa I think some
authoritarian governments would welcome
that answer but assume the kind of
calculus that kind of calculus I think
is that that kind of calculus is likely
to be right in the sense that it should
scale up to be the dominant answer cast
aside how much empirical theoretical and
values conflict we should honestly
acknowledge and debating the rightness
of how we pursue a better life
before I take questions I should
apologize for speaking so quickly I
think today was slower than yesterday
but I still have some work to do so I'd
love to hear your questions but what is
the second problem as you
so I think what I was trying to get at
was if you question that we've already
arrived at a pretty simple and
straightforward method to prioritize
among actions then you the the inside I
think cuts in two separate directions
that are somewhat in tension with each
other one is let's just focus on doing
the most good we can in a sort of
logical way and aspire to fulfill the
original ambition of cost-benefit
analysis or effective altruism but let's
take into account more constraints and
that might make some actions seem less
attractive even though they seemed more
attractive before but I evoke the
protesters because I also feel like
sometimes like I would feel weird if the
upshot of this whole conversation was be
more cautious right it feels to me like
part of what I'm getting at is also that
sometimes somebody might say it's not
like the most good I can do in any
conventional sense where I can sort of
make an expected utility judgment and
it's like really the best option from
that perspective but I don't feel like I
have a choice and I have to do this so I
feel like there's work to do in both
directions like maybe there's still some
weighing of utility and of strategy even
in the realm where people have done
something as a matter of conscience but
there's also a need to be more practical
and realistic and politically savvy when
we've chosen to do something that is
sort of like technically justified yes
Beck you definitely a student so why
don't the key parameters of cost-benefit
of the houses this country one of the
problems for climate change is most of
the cost of any decades in the future
how in the world do you deal with that
oh that's a great question
so my kids understand discounting very
well as all kids do right there's these
great experiments you might know about
that we're done at the big nursery
school at Stanford showing how it is
that kids struggle when they're told
that they'll get extra candy if they
wait and then trying to match up that
behavior to a lot of life outcomes later
on I think like let me start by saying
like I think it'd be crazy to
get rid of dis cunning but there are a
couple of ways in which I think it would
be really helpful to be less Orthodox
about it so let's start with current
preferences people might have that map
onto discounting so I might believe that
the right thing to do for society is to
counterbalance the natural present dis
bias that we have I don't want to die
tomorrow I want to have you know what I
need with actually a policy that that
does the opposite of discounting
precisely because our politics are
already biased that's to me a perfectly
sensible legitimate move in the analysis
and no it's not true that we can't model
that so then beyond that there are more
complexities right there might be other
rationales that one might have for
having a discount curve that that looks
kind of funky but let's just start by
opening up the conversation and saying
we are not bereft of tools either tools
for deliberation or tools for
technically modeling that really force
us into a straitjacket and make this
conversation quite so simple ever right
and then from there you know we see
where we go yeah
[Music]
translated across different problems so
you refer to the protesters in Hong Kong
which feels like very individual for
talking about I went to a certain action
for whatever values are important to ISM
figures not an accident that altruism is
bedeviled those of us who kind of came
up through the ranks academically by
being engaged with the idea of rational
action in part both I mean benefiting
from paradigms that heavily made use of
it but also at times seeing its tensions
and contradictions and limitations
because you know you could certainly
imagine somebody who says I want to be
deeply rational and for me altruism only
is altruism when it does nothing to
benefit me right and yet like the
conventional like worth rhetorical case
we make for our tourism generally has
the following structure like if if I'm
giving a speech and I'm exhorting people
to volunteering it will almost always
have an element of like do good for
others you will also be doing good for
yourself you'll be giving back to if not
you your community and that matters to
you like whatever so so I don't want to
be overly sort of technical and and
suggests that a complete separation
between what only benefits others and
what benefits you is desirable in policy
making or making your own choices but it
is helpful to recognize that the concept
is useful in part because sometimes do
things people do things that they think
are in the public's interest but they're
mostly self-serving right so it is
helpful to have some way of pushing back
and getting people to try to distinguish
the interests involved and climate is a
good example like there are
justifications for the veldt and Rodan
it should have been all kinds of other
infrastructure projects that have a
development angle that might come from a
kind of like also help save the planet
climate change perspective and it's
never
been a bad thing to try to unpack the
different agendas that people might have
that motivate them so long as it doesn't
make us completely cynical right I feel
like just as it's important to
disentangle the interest that one might
have that are mostly personal regarding
from what good you're actually doing for
others it's also important not to
believe that whenever those things
converge that somehow that makes your
actions legitimate yeah one thing that
you spoke about was sort of the
importance of embracing like sort of
evaluative pluralism so that we can have
at least governmental actors optimize
their ability to see the weight of
different decisions interact with one
another and I guess I have two questions
on this front first of all my question
is I guess how we can do this and how
government can like can act more
effectively to do this and then second
of all whether this is something that
you think Sam's only for governmental
actors or just sort of effective
altruism at a more individual level
definitely at a more individual level -
and Ruth Chang's work I think is
interesting and trying to sort of
develop a set of concepts that help
people weigh options but not do so by
trying to seek to convert everything to
a common quantitative metric and it
suggests that though the ideas behind
the term something is on a par with
something else I can do real work to
some degree and you know expanding from
that I would say well you know whatever
methodology you use whether it's for
altruism or for government
decision-making it's a wonderful thing
if you can develop a capacity to hear
from different people who are not
unreasonable how they weigh the merits
right I think that the hard thing begins
to be both in that individual context
but even more so in the governmental
context the decision costs and there of
two kinds right so one is just it's hard
enough and costly to get one analysis
done and for government sometimes that
takes seven years so now you want three
like where are you crazy but you know
related to that not only the cost in
terms of resources but the the modal
impact of more analysis on government
action is less action right just like
procedural rights
many benefits but often the result is
everybody becomes a veto player right so
so I think the hard work on the
institutional structure side isn't so
much to describe the kinds of analyses
that one would like to see more of like
I think Sunstein does a killer job in
the arithmetic of arsenic of describing
three different dose couple different
dose response curves that are all
plausible and have different assumptions
and I can imagine working with a gifted
user interface designer on the digital
side to think about how you present the
information digitally to a decision
maker to try to strike an optimal or
semi optimal balance of trust and
distrust in these different metrics and
to get the the assumptions to sort of be
highlighted the harder thing is then to
ask well how do we make a system like
that work in a way that doesn't paralyze
us but I'm pretty comfortably do that
yeah yeah expanding the factors that we
see within the epa for instance you know
maybe you're not considering what sort
of impacts that might have on housing
for instance and it seems logical it of
course that would get considered but
maybe you run the analysis and you've
consulted every possible agency that you
needed to to make sure this analysis is
good and somebody comes at the 11th hour
is like wait you forgot to like thing
about X or Y or Z and then you've got to
incorporate that again and it seems like
that you might lose a little bit of
specialty and sort of like calling for
so much like cross
analysis of sorts you know you could
imagine that you just have one big
central group that just like does all
this work and suddenly you don't have
all these different agency heads that
it's traditionally we find the executive
branch but instead you've just got one
water agency that looks at everything it
handles everything and you know whether
that's plausible or not yeah I think
that has certain ramifications that
people might find unsettled you really
nicely put your finger on how a core
idea intention in my whole discussion is
the role of specialization so I have a
couple things to say about that but let
me just first note that one one way to
interpret your your comment is actually
to say you've just provided a pretty
accurate description of how the US
government however imperfectly does this
stuff because essentially the way it
works out the day-in day-out
is the agencies have a degree of
specialization and they essentially work
on the first draft of one of these
analyses then it goes to a cadre of
generalists at the Office of Management
and Budget
who debate and discuss with him in that
deliberation like if if I were to tell a
very positive story about CBA I would
highlight that tension between the
experts that did it in the agency and
the generalists were kind of pushing
back on fairly technical things and
that's one way we sort of get at these
multiple analyses but I would say
underlying that that whole effort is
still the idea the fiction I would say
that you can collapse a cell into the
one right analysis in some sense but if
you vary that and then you take
seriously the possibility of different
analyses then that foregrounds a little
bit more the fact that as Steve Brier
actually nicely put it in a book called
breaking the vicious cycle or circle
breaking the vicious circle or cycle
circle I think that he wrote before
going on the bench that expertise has
always been a two-edged sword it's
always been both blinding to the way
common sense is applied and the way
other people think through problems but
it's been a stupendous tool to solve
problems I'm looking for ways to titrate
that in different ways to try to get at
different problems and in the effective
altruism context one way that this comes
up is I think for effective altruists
it's a little under
theorized what I do if I've specialized
in refugee protection for example and
not only because of path-dependent like
I happen to take some courses at it at
Yale Law School and whatever but because
I actually feel like my personality
makes me really really well-suited to
the mix of Social Work and disaster
response that that entails and but what
if it turns out that my own judgement
and it turns out to be nothing but
myself regarding preferences and and the
eye system judges me to actually be more
useful as an investment banker I mean to
just make it extreme but more useful as
I don't know what a social worker
working in New Haven and you know how do
you think about all that extra knowledge
I've already gained if it's not like
totally enhancing my ability to deliver
value so I I would like to live in a
world where people can make use of that
and have a preference over it but in
both contexts that the specialists are
forced systematically to tangle with
people whose special value comes from
not being specialists just like judges
generally are generals you think your
expertise influences the way you see
this and the way your argument at the
risk of sounding kind of comically
circular myself it seems as though the
first lecture was there are these big
issues that we're worried about right a
nuclear proliferation climate change
there's whole host of issues and it
seems a little bit though is that you're
performing husband if it analysis some
ways to perform cost-benefit analysis
right you look this way you're kind of
then you get these trade-offs and do you
think of it this way you get these
trade-offs so what are kind of those
route assumptions as route thank you
I'll try to talk more a little about
that tomorrow but you so a couple
thoughts there's a line somewhere in
there that I didn't say in exactly the
terms I had written it down but I'll try
to reconstruct it right now I worry that
there is a little bit of a circularity
in a piece of my analysis and I want to
own that but I think the circularity is
not only because of me I think it's
actually a deeper feature of the world
and kind of goes a little bit like this
so suppose that I like the idea of
cost-benefit analysis but I'm also
making a play for not only Prudential
judgments about politics but more candor
about the fact that different values are
important to people in different ways so
I want those values to be taken
seriously not all values might count the
same for me right but how do I pick
among those values without using
something like cost-benefit analysis so
meaning to put it in slightly different
terms you could say there's a kind of
weak perfectionism that's built into
almost any coherent cost-benefit
analysis but I worry that that sort of
collapse is a little into a discussion
of what values are more you know good so
I feel like as a temporary move while we
figured that out as a civilization it's
at least better to be candid about where
the moves are being made that are
driving the analysis particularly at a
time when there's it's sort of ironic I
feel like us you know one of the
background things that's happening in a
discussion about this is I think the
world is growing more polarized there is
this is my stylized depiction of it
others might have a slightly different
view of it but I feel like among people
who are highly educated who are in the
knowledge professions there's an
increasing embrace of the idea that
highly technical methods cannot force
the answer science etc and among many
many others there's an increasing
rejection of that so I feel like that
polarization is a challenge that we're
facing and at a minimum I want some
acknowledgement among the people who are
most faithful in the tech technical and
the scientific of the different ways
that people fundamentally see the world
and why that belongs somewhere in our
politics but I'm still struggling with
this yeah
I think people have long seen it as a
way of building coalitions to some
extent this is partly my point about
Clinton especially among people who
might otherwise disagree about things
like look it's not that your values are
right or mine are right it's that you
know it's an empirical question let's
get the scientists in here and settle it
and let's see politicize as much as
possible why don't we agree on the
scientists and should be on the panel
and you know we'll be it for anyone to
dismiss the extraordinary role that
scientific thinking generally has played
in advancing human civilization and I'm
being a little loose in how sometimes
you respect
technical sometimes are you science
sometimes use technocratic but did the
general idea that technical knowledge
can be politicized is very attractive I
worry that that has not we've sort of
taken that as far as we can and now
we're suffering from having gone too far
in that direction and questions about
the timing of when you impose a
particular regulatory policy change as
people struggle to get used to these
norms get really difficult especially
once you touch anything that sort of
social or cultural like issues involving
LGBT rights for example so there's some
needs some for some very careful
thinking but at a minimum I think step
one is don't throw out all this
technique but don't expect so much of it
because if we expect too much of it
we're not going to get either the full
benefit of it nor winging it at the goal
that we want which is to govern in a
sensible way okay yeah
can you speak to sort of tension between
using sort of your evaluative pluralism
and enacting it in cases where
counterparties aren't using the same
stringent thorough or value or maybe any
evaluative techniques right so I'm
thinking particularly of like the
government right
by eating particular legislators which
are legislating ways that they can have
more power whether through
gerrymandering their own bar bill which
reduces the dialogue for the benefit of
putting forward whatever policy their
side thinks is right and and sort of you
know how this how does this idea map on
to the sort of counter incentives of
reducing discussion just pushing things
there I think that's great and in a way
I want to connect it to the previous
question because when one answer would
have been right like well we get people
to embrace more and more that there are
certain Enlightenment values that help
us right solve like arbiter disputes and
they are mostly of a certain kind and
they depend on expertise and that's
actually served as well and like do you
really want to walk away from that I
would say I'm looking for a set of
shared values that are necessary for
common conversation in any
self-governing entity I can imagine
certainly including in America in North
Carolina and California etc and I have
not believed that the only set of common
values that would enable that
conversation are science and technical
analysis right they are one and they're
an important one but let's take human
dignity as one like I think it should
bother all Americans that some Americans
don't live with dignity you know what
they do about it it might depend on any
number of things but but some degree of
common concern or some degree for of
engagement and like what the proper
norms are for a political conversation
or for a set of political institutions
to operate fairly is key right and I've
written a little bit about you know how
when there are stresses on this there
are all kinds of consequences and
difficulties and why it's difficult to
put that back together again but I guess
you know it it's always been worrisome
to me to think that the the display of
authority that is involved in deploying
technical knowledge in a way that takes
human needs that are asserted in a
proper and respectful way and puts them
aside
I feel that it's sort of concerning
right so so I think where that leaves me
as a good administrative law person that
I sort of am in my heart is thinking of
the scientific and the technical is one
of several kind of streams that have to
be grounded in norms of political
conversation others being that we care
about democracy that we care about
adjudicatory fairness for example and
then the difficulty is in designing
institutions that can take all of that
seriously but we have done that like if
you think about so let me in vote let me
put this in very academic terms so it
doesn't sound like I'm just like issuing
an opinion man you know as a public
official but so so one thing I take away
from the work of Daniel carpenter who's
you know a political scientist whose
work I admire is an effort to blur the
distinction between a good
organizational politician and a good
scientific and technical thinker and his
argument is that if you look at a really
effective FDA Commissioner there's
somebody who can count votes in the
legislature who can read the journals
who can understand those response curves
who can figure out like what's driving
the White House's anxiety about this
announcement tomorrow and is like trying
to build around her or him a group of
people who are going to be the shock
absorbers who take that and process it
in some way I mean that again is maybe a
way of also responding the circularity
point to sort of own that circularity
and and to be able to be accountable for
it and in the choices of how you then
justify your agency's actions you're
partly contributing to the democratic
conversation Bob and then places and I
guess I have a question about who the
addressee of the
I completely applaud the idea of making
cost-benefit imbalances more open and
more responsive to the many factors that
it excludes but if I'm thinking about
the greatest threat now to
administration its its politicalization
and the need for administrators to
insulate themselves for what is
increasingly a politicized forms of
control which are not subject to the
kind of democratic dialogue you're
describing because of conditions of
polarization so paradoxically if I think
of my ideal administrator they do but
you'd say but on the other hand you
develop they develop cost benefit
analysis precisely to insulate from
political control and if I think of the
need now for administrators and mostly
its to insulate from a certain kind of
political control and so that raises the
question of whom exactly are you talking
to thank you for your question my main
audience are undergraduates who are
interested in either effective altruism
or the role of science because I feel
like this is a generation long struggle
and effort and it will continue I mean
more than a generation but in a way I'm
hoping to abstract a little bit from the
moment important though it is and smooth
right and when I think about the risks I
would situate some risks in
politicization some risks in politics
right and you know what politics
prevails or doesn't some risks in
failure to acknowledge the
distributional maybe political
implications of technical decisions
right and all of that together then
paint some more complicated picture that
I hope our undergrads have enough time
to solve because you know we we won't
completely but I mean that's another way
of saying elections have consequences
for example like so in in terms that
will be familiar to you I would say and
many others perhaps I would say one
thing that's Scalia justice the late
Justice Antonin Scalia figured out I
think in in a way that to his credit I
would say is that the best justification
for having an administrative bureaucracy
that could be about science to some
extent but also necessarily about
politics and about law
was never purely expertise right I think
he came to understand the limitations
and that for a number of reasons like
expertise can be good but it fails at
times it also is not always legitimate
right so it had to be situated somewhere
else and I think in some ways he
situated it in the structural politics
that allowed some room for democracy
like I don't know if he ever used that
combination of words but when he was
still a fan of Chevron he was sort of
saying like look you know administrators
are not completely under the thumb of a
president but there's some political
accountability there right within limits
right so in some ways we're left to
figure out what how do you impose those
limits enough so that you have
guardrails and don't go off the rails
tomorrow but you know Robert was talking
about what Dan carpenter was talking
about how do you try to navigate a
unpleasant political structure to do the
best you can and you were saying well
the political structure may be really
difficult to maneuver especially if you
have safe seats and you know the
importance of extreme interests for
people who are facing primaries and safe
seats that is safe for the party but not
safe for the incumbent and if we have
more of those the political pressures
become more anti-democratic in a sense
you know that that the influence of
extreme interest
good comment amplified so I'm wondering
what you think about the structures you
mentioned it how do we trying to push
back negative features of the structure
itself there are several puzzles and
difficulties in in giving a good
response so let me start by
acknowledging that in the moments some
of the action space for a principled
Civic actor it surely has to depend on
norms right and if they've declined then
there's there's a natural process of
like Oh trust but verify like you know
no you level the some of it here like
you find them of a different party and
they acted this way I'm gonna act this
way and then you get a kind of
escalation so so I certainly wouldn't
want concern for the long-term norms to
be completely disempowering to people
who need to compete with each other if
there's going to be some possibility for
norms to develop in a certain way but
that's only a piece of it I would say
another way that your good question
relates to your previous question locks
are very tests what is your name so okay
ISM I will say just I have a little riff
in the talk tomorrow which I'll just
anticipate we're talking about a concept
that called civic judgment which is I'm
trying to give a name and draw a box
around political savvy that is not
deployed primarily for self-serving ends
and takes account of norms and
constraints and I'm trying to do that
because I think the word politics has
been so loaded with different meanings
so like politicized is a kind of
reference to politics that is very
negative in connotation partisan
politics is one thing but if somebody
were to ask me is a multi-member court
political as a social scientists I said
well of course like people count votes
and they think about each other and they
are in you know reciprocal contact with
each other but if they asked me in
somewhat different context is a court
political and I felt like they meant
partisan I would say no well we aspire
not to be and I don't think we are right
and we try hard
not to be we try hard for it not to
matter you know whether some is a
Republican or Democrat or or and not on
the above when they you know argue a
case before us but I am trying to make
space in all these stocks for a kind of
judgment that I will call civic judgment
that is aware of the context of things
and it does feel to me like that that is
compatible with a medium the long term
effort to build institutions and and
build coalitions but it's also
compatible with being savvy about how
not to be left out of the conversation
wondering about that map over a 10-year
window and all of that and so
administration while pushing for dynamic
scoring and they were saying you know
you can't just but it was it was all
basically a proxy for fuzzy math that
somebody went sick
right and so and that's the bureaucrats
won that battle then but they just lost
that battle and now you know the 2017
tax bill yeah I remember scoring with
fuzzy math being a euphemism for what
was put into the models so so I guess my
question is if if you're pushing for a
world in which there's going to be a lot
more scope for much more complex
speculative theorizing about the effects
of any
even policy aren't you also gonna be
pushing for the world in which is much
more potential to capture apparently
technical analysis or you know
flagrantly party's name there's some
risk of that and what's more I will even
go one step further and suggesting that
our a critique that would push me and
maybe rightly so is to say well you're
actually trying to even allow for some
weighing of costs and benefits to
include like the political backlash
right and think of what an unprincipled
administration could do with that if
they were actually able to cite that as
an appropriate concern I guess my answer
would start by saying my hope in a
nutshell about CBA is to ask more of it
and expect less from it to push it to be
a more candid assessment of what it is
that ought to matter for society and not
to rely on the sort of circa 1970s tools
that we had at the time but also to not
elevate it in our discourse or in our
institutions to a quite as central role
as the sort of fundamental technique
that is going to arbiter what actually
happens not that it ever completely has
been right but sometimes there's an
ambition to put it there so that would
then lead me in a place where I'd
acknowledge that a potential cost of my
own inclination is that the dynamic
scoring thing would have gone through
because that's very simpatico with
generally speaking the direction I'd
like to go but it might have been done
poorly it might have been an excuse and
yet the you know practical person in me
asks if we hadn't had dynamics core and
what would that have done in the tax
bill this last time around I don't think
it would have stopped it from passing
and I do think a subtext and everything
I'm saying is elections matter like
there is a part of this that is really
about building coalitions or failing to
do so and that stings in a democracy
sometimes we face a high cost for the
democracy that we believe in when we
don't necessarily agree with what
follows I mean that then pushes us in
the direction well are the rules the
game fair so I would say as it gets
closer to questions about are the rules
of the game fair I think that that
political
he becomes more important to make sure
that this doesn't just become unilateral
disarmament which then further erodes
the norms over time no question was sort
of an allegation saying that in some
ways agreeing with you and saying you
know one of the things we need to bring
in is how our decisions impacts the
rules of the game right seeing decisions
to change the filibuster rule seeing
decisions to use gerrymandering right
and I may be alleging that there's not
been enough credence given to that side
of things
it's complicated like I feel like it's
right to weigh the consequences for a
system that has as part of its premises
that is supposed to be balanced and fair
in the competition for political power I
think it gets tricky because I want
government decision-makers to be
thoughtful about how they can hold
together coalitions and not overly
diminish people's trust in the entire
system but I also like probably most of
you don't want those considerations too
sometimes to always outweigh other
reasons why you might pursue a policy so
you know when writing a book that was
partially about Franklin Roosevelt and
having reorganized government I came
across as just some evidence that I was
never able to fully follow up on and I
think there's probably already a
literature on this although I might have
my take on it which is about how so part
of my argument was that Roosevelt really
was key in expanding the operations of
the modern White House to sort of what
it is now it wasn't like Reagan or
Truman like it was really that the the
kernel of it was how Roosevelt ran the
White House and there were like
decisions about grants that were being
funneled to the White House and were
being affected by the White House so
like I hope that my notion of civic
judgment is like protecting us from like
self dealing that way but there was also
a kind of political judgment that is
about trying to understand how macro
policies or having systematically
different effects on different parts of
the country
and you know ignoring that has
consequences too much better
we are answers to these questions raised
for me the question on how does the
administrator think differently than the
politician thinks in the modeling that
you're doing so if we expand this notion
of civil judgment it looks like The
Statesman and then how do you imagine
politicians thinking that's how I want
the politician to be more like an
administrator but but never completely
to collapse the distinction and you
could say certainly relative to the
conception of an administrator that
Professor Sunstein might have I want
that minister to be more like a
politician right so I want them to be
closer together but not the same and I
would say yes okay so a politician has a
job that allows her to explicitly
consider partisan considerations within
limits right it is okay for an elected
offense takes Minh like completely to
say I have a project that's gonna take
25 years like I may not be in this
office for 25 years but I have that
project so I want my coalition to be
viable for that amount of time so we
have to sequence these things the most
socially valuable thing is going to come
in three years and that right now most
like coalition building thing is going
to come now I think that's an
appropriate kind of set of
considerations for a political figure
like a legislator an administrator has
to work somewhat differently and and
keep a good bit of room in his or her
thinking for the purposes and logic and
structure of the kind of fiduciary
duties that have been turned over to her
so that she is not so much being sort of
like focused on her long term coalition
but about what it will take for the
agency to perform its functions
effectively over time which is still
about vote counting still about the
budget still in some ways about how the
public views the agency but a different
cast yeah how do you think that agency
being
turning things into a technical question
actually protects them and you might
want answer to Robert and some of the
other questions would be that everyone
knows intuitively that there's some
degree of politics involved and they
they get that it's a bit of a sham that
they've turned that we've turned it into
a technical question and therefore
you're not actually protecting the this
agency by pretending that this is by
pretending that it's more technical than
it is so one response may be yes it may
seem like I am opening up the agency to
more politics at a time when politics is
messed up but I actually think that more
politics actually I love that so one
chance right no no but Allah but it it's
sort of cracks I think a change in my
own thinking about what is happening
when an agency asserts technical
expertise when I first started thinking
about this I thought that it was that
you you could model it as so imagine a
game and the agency says like it's a
technical question we're putting our
foot down and then like nature decides
whether that actually pays off or not
and there's a risk that the agency's
assertion of technical knowledge will
actually make the agency sort of be
rejected more by the public because the
agency has given up an opportunity to
sort of sell its its package of goals in
another way either by building
coalitions with the legislature or by
kind of defending this as a popular
program that fits with what the
administration wants to do there's like
a risk element but it generally is a
good thing for the agency to do I now
think about this differently as probably
driven by the fact that there are two
different kinds of assertions of
technical knowledge one kind is to say
members of the public we hereby declare
that we're scientists
don't bother we've got it under control
don't call us we'll call you
it's it's fine like it's all happening
humming in the background so I would say
what would be a good example of that
well maybe the people who
run like market operations for the
Federal Reserve like it's not just that
monetary policy is technical it's the
execution of it at some level like leave
us alone there's another kind of
assertion of technical expertise which
is what I think the FDA does more often
which is a subtle appeal to values that
the public is concerned with so if you
kind of like really to like if you'd
listened to a David Kessler press
conference or a Peggy Hamburg press
conference or others they're not talking
to scientists primarily they're talking
to public officials and opinion leaders
and they're trying to have an overlap
where what they say is not going to be
rejected by the scientist but if you
draw the Venn diagram it's going to be
intelligible to others and in that
respect I think they're more like other
public officials perhaps including
judges where there's some sort of like
rhetorical coalition-building happening
where the technical knowledge is sort of
in dialogue with the set of values that
the public believes it has a right to be
at have an opinion about right so that's
a different assertion of technical
knowledge and it's one that forces the
agency to be in some dialogue with the
public right and you know I got to flesh
that out a little bit but I do think
that the subcategory of like asserting
technical expertise actually can be
disaggregated a bit but I didn't see
that you know some years back I think
that when I was taking administrative
law with Professor Jeremy Shaw and I
came across one of his articles called
Pro delegation : Y administrators should
make political decisions I was persuaded
then that he understood something were
actually that that I was learning from
him his understanding that rang true to
me of how it is that administrators were
inevitably if they were going to be
technically successful had to anticipate
roadblocks that were right at the
intersection of the technical and the
political like not having the right
budget having local officials opposed
what you're doing fighting you have a
problem with your staff and his argument
was effectively that the problem really
isn't that administrators are making
political policy decisions the problem
is if they're not accountable
in a way that binds the scope of what
they can legitimately do one forces them
to give reasons and forces them to be
reviewed right and if we have those
structures in place and we shouldn't
worry so much about them making
decisions that have some serious
policy-making element for that reason I
have always found it not surprising that
when I teach administrative law my
students tend to come around including
the ones who are initially skeptical of
Chevron to the following general
conclusion they don't completely agree
with each other necessarily whatever
judicial opinion they read but they
realized that actually even an
administrator that is subject to like
intrusive like de novo review from a
court or that is subject to a
legislature that doesn't want the
administrator have any discretion is
gonna end up being in some ways needed
by the other institutions to arbiter the
really hard factual questions
unless we totally Rican seep of the
legislature and imagine like a bunch of
specialists running around in
congressional committees actually
reviewing what the agency is doing in
real time somehow and that realization I
think just gives them a more nuanced
perspective on these debates I think
they they don't think that the question
about Chevron is is like not important
but they think it's sort of less
important than the practicalities of
what the norms will allow the
administrator to control to some degree
just open in that last answer I said
norms and administrators so maybe that's
not a bad thing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]